das ist eine dramatische entwicklung die
zahl der infizierten mit dem corona
videos ist von gestern auf heute um 14
1840 gestiegen doch jetzt könnte
künstliche intelligenz helfen die
ausbreitung einzudämmen und vielleicht
hat sie schon ein heilmittel gefunden
klicks um science fiction die spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
14 1480 mehr infizierte an einem tag
haben die hoffnung zunichte gemacht dass
die ausbreitung des virus langsam
eingedämmt wird überhaupt sind die
zahlen aus china leider sehr
unzuverlässig china zählt infizierten
ohne symptome nicht mehr zu den
infizierten was gegen internationale
standards verstößt und die einschätzung
nach fast gänzlich unmöglich macht der
epidemie und ein neues diagnoseverfahren
scheint für den starken anstieg der
fallzahlen der infizierten mit dem saas
kopf 2 virus wie das virus jetzt
offiziell bezeichnet wird verantwortlich
zu sein die erkrankung wird jetzt cupid
19 genannt selbst forschungen des
deutschen robert koch-instituts
schließen jetzt eine pandemie nicht mehr
aus könnte künstliche intelligenz aber
jetzt helfen denn es war ein algorithmus
der bereits ende des vergangenen jahres
2009 10 vor einem erreger in der
chinesischen stadt wo hahn warnte die
big data algorithmen waren damit
deutlich schneller als die zuständige us
behörde und die
weltgesundheitsorganisation who die erst
am 19 januar alarm schlug doch nicht nur
bei der solchen früherkennung sondern
auch bei der diagnose und der suche nach
heilmitteln gegen die korona während
wird die macht der künstlichen
intelligenz jetzt deutlich der
algorithmus wurde von dem kanadischen
unternehmen blut dort entwickelt dessen
kundinnen und kunden wurden bereits ende
dezember 2009 10 vor allem erreger
gewarnt der sich in der chinesischen
stadt wuchern ausbreitet die software
der firma hatte dafür nachrichten
infektions meldungen und flugdaten
analysiert heraus kam ein trend der dann
mithilfe menschlicher intelligenz
genauer analysiert werden konnte
diese vorhersage der künstlichen
intelligenz wurde aber achtung sechs
tage vor der ersten meldung einer
offiziellen behörde veröffentlicht denn
erst am sechsten januar die us behörde
centers for disease control and
prevention eine
diese warnung heraus die
weltgesundheitsorganisation wto folgte
am 9 januar
das ist wirklich ziemlich verblüffend
das ganze erinnert ein wenig an die
frühen versuche von google grippe
ausbrüche vorherzusagen google flu hatte
sich auf suchanfragen spezialisiert den
der dienst dann mit daten der behörden
ab doch wirklich erfolgreich war google
flu juni 2009 hatte der dienst die h1n1
grippe verpasst in den jahren 2012 und
2013 dagegen wurde die grippesaison um
ganze 140 prozent überschätzt doch
seitdem hat sich technisch viel getan
und riesige datenmengen können sehr viel
effizienter und auch schneller
analysiert werden daten sind heute viel
besser verfügbar fachleute der
us-universität johns hopkins university
stellen auf einer webseite alle corona
in fraktionen die bislang von den
behörden gemeldet wurden in echtzeit
online ebenso die damit verbundenen
todesfälle außerdem online ist die
webseite health map auf der man sich
über die aktuellen infektionsfälle aller
möglichen krankheiten von ebola bis hin
zur grippe informieren kann
doch nicht nur die vorhersagen zu einer
möglichen epidemie basieren mittlerweile
aufs künstliche intelligenz ki um
herauszufinden ob man erkrankt ist
braucht man in der theorie nicht mal
mehr eine ärztin oder einen arzt diese
werden ersetzt durch jackpots
beispielsweise durch den facebook bot er
befragt seine patientinnen und patienten
per messenger chat und berät sie dann
bezüglich des zita virus und zwar ohne
wartezeit und außerdem auch gratis jetzt
gibt es auch bots die bei der diagnose
des corona virus helfen das hilfsmittel
hierbei gezielte fragen wie waren sie in
der letzten zeit in china oder haben sie
kontakt mit jemanden der in china war
falls die nutzerinnen und nutzer an
grippeähnlichen symptomen leiden wie
fieber oder husten ist damit zumindest
schon mal einen anfangsverdacht gegeben
und den patientinnen und patienten wird
nahegelegt sich in eine praxis oder
notaufnahme zu begeben nach angaben der
unternehmen beruht diese software auf
den daten und leitlinien die die us
behörde centers for disease control and
prevention herausgegeben hat diese
kriterien legen fest unter welchen
umständen menschen auf das kroner virus
untersucht werden sollen dazu brett
young green der entwickler eines solchen
bots wir sind der meinung dass wir
menschen wirklich dabei unterstützen
können wir können ihnen hinweise geben
ob und wann sie sich in behandlung geben
müssen
wir können sie aber auch davon abhalten
wenn ein solcher test nicht erforderlich
ist doch die ausbreitung des corona wir
es macht nicht nur deutlich dass
künstliche intel
wenn es zu solchen früherkennung und zur
diagnose beitragen kann also wird man
suchen derzeit auch fieberhaft nach
möglichen heilmitteln und therapien
sie werden vermehrt dazu eingesetzt die
moleküle varianten in den riesigen
datenbanken durchzugehen und mit bereits
erfassten naturstoffen abzugleichen zu
meldet beispielsweise das britische
unternehmen bmw einen möglichen erfolg
demnach habe die eigene software
plattform mit hilfe von maschinellem
lernen molekül kandidaten identifiziert
die das corona virus möglicherweise
bekämpfen könnten daran artikel in der
fachzeitschrift lancet handelt es sich
um eine substanz die bereits also rheuma
medikament eingesetzt wird die rede ist
von dem so genannten janus kinase
inhibitor barisic der als
entzündungshemmend geht diese substanz
könnte möglicherweise verhindern dass
das virus über einen zellulären vorgang
namens endozytose india viola zellen
gelangen kann dabei handelt es sich um
spezialisierte zellen die in der lunge
vorkommen in dem fachartikel schlagen
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler vor das mittel bei
patientinnen und patienten mit
atemwegserkrankungen zu testen wir haben
eine playlist mit allen infos zur
infektion zusammengestellt dafür hier
klicken und wir freuen uns über jede
unterstützung für unsere täglichen
videos werde gerne kanal mit geht dann
bekommt er die videos auch früher vor
allen anderen das geht hier unter dem
video oder auf unserer kanalseite also
draufklicken angucken abonnieren klicks
um science-fiction bis dann bleibt dran